welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode 6 the series finale so this is
christmas a title that reminds us that
this show is at its heart a christmas
treat the title also citing john lennon
and yoko ono's happy xmas war is over
and that song's children's choir much
like the angelic voices of this episode
happy christmas let's break down this
finale shot by shot for everything
interesting you might have missed and
heads up i am gonna include spoilers for
both hawkeye and spiderman no way home
also you can get some great holiday
gifts by checking out our new limited
edition hawkeye shirts and our awesome
strange entanglement shirt along with a
kingpin inspired long live the king
shirt at newrockstarsmerch.com the
episode opens with the king wilson fizz
kingpin vincent d'onofrio returning in
the same delivery as the character in
the netflix marvel daredevil this first
shot we see of him is actually his cane
an interesting parallel to our very
first shot of charlie cox matt murdock
and spider-man no way home kane first
and as fisk approaches the camera shoots
him from below and then shoots eleanor
down from above and then throughout the
scene continues to frame kingpin huge
from the surface of his desk and in the
foreground and then when it cuts back to
eleanor she is small in frame on the
other side of the desk just some forced
perspective to heighten the size
differential and to make kingpin all the
more intimidating there's also a
reflection of this in the door behind
eleanor giving us the sense that he is
surrounding her eleanor begins we've had
a good relationship haven't we wilson
yes
yes kingpin has gotten good at reading
people and d'onofrio twitches his eye
from the very beginning of the scene
until it just lashes out in a rage by
the scene's end the twitching eye also
foreshadows his off-screen fate when he
is shot by maya lopez but as in the
daredevil comics we'll probably just
walk away blinded there's a shot of
midtown manhattan that shows the hell's
kitchen neighborhood the domain of
kingpin kind of the heart of kingpin's
grip on the city and of course the
stomping grounds of matt murdock and you
can see some industrial steam blocking
out the view of the skyline but there's
actually a new tower added between the
empire state building and the bank of
america tower on the right side of frame
and those really really tall central
park towers on the left i don't think
this tower exists in real life and yes
it is interesting that it is masked by
steam here this is roughly where
avengers tower used to be located that
tower was always cgi'd over the real
life met life building which is located
beside grand central station however
this episode actually shows us the
metlife building later on in a shot of
comcast tower aka 30 rock but in that
shot there is that large blue tower
right beside it that i also don't think
exists in real life so the mcu might
have actually relocated former avengers
tower slightly in the city's geography
and the steam back in that establishing
shot makes me wonder if something was
being masked from this building because
we know in far from home spider-man
sailed right through a new atrium that
was constructed in that tower by its new
occupant this series doesn't really
confirm the answer to that but it could
be fisk tower or the fantastic four
baxter building maya lopez meets with
kazzy and kingpin who now changed into a
red hawaiian shirt his exact outfit from
the cover of the spider-man comic family
business notice how fisk only knows
certain words in asl i always taught you
to keep a low profile
he knows a low profile in sign language
probably a recurring reminder that he
has repeated since she was young maya
claims to have dropped her ronin pursuit
but kingpin does not buy it and notice
how his eye twitch returns and he tells
kazzy the people
need to be reminded
that the city belongs to me
echoing the kind of words he would use
in the netflix daredevil show i wanted
to make this city
something better
than it is
something beautiful
you took that away from me
this is my city
my family then a montage shows clint and
kate assembling a whole bunch of trick
arrows one of many christmas movie
homages in this episode recalling that
planning montage and home alone you'll
notice they have another pim arrowhead
but whereas the previous one glowed blue
the color for pim discs that enlarged
stuff this one has a red interior the
color of pin particles and discs that
shrink things and along with too
dangerous the other labels read airbag
freeze flashbomb icebreaker all things
we see used in the final battle one uses
electromagnetism to attract metal which
is similar text how cap would retract
his shield to his arm and age of ultron
then a series of stark arrowheads that
are tipped with red and gold of course
iron man's colors ones that were
probably designed by tony stark for
clint kate recalls the episode one
prologue when she saw clint fighting
chitari without any superpowers or tech
unlike iron man in that battle you
showed me that being a hero isn't just
for people who can fly or shoot lasers
out of their hands is for anyone but i
guess being a hero is for people using
the weapon built by the guys who shoot
lasers out of their hands we see a
caravan of trust abroad trucks pulling
up to 30 rock
yes once again we here dance to the
sugar plum fairy from tchaikovsky's
nutcracker and that classical music
evokes the way hans gruber's crew was
scored with ode to joy as they arrived
in die hard
ivan also says red one in position like
he's part of the red squadron in star
wars elena arrives to the party in a
green coat another production design
element pulled from home alone in which
several shots of that movie have both
red and green somewhere in the frame
like the mcallister's year-round yet
still christmasy wallpaper which they
did to give that movie an all-time
christmasy feel this episode often does
the same thing not just with christmas
decorations everywhere literally in the
costuming of red and green suited track
suit bros and just random background set
decorations clint spots kazzy's sniper
in the champagne and he quickly uses a
serving platter to deflect the bullet
and all hell breaks loose kate boards
the elevator with yelena and wrestles
with her until the top tears away to her
new purple hawkeye archer top which i
just really appreciate because it was
the elena's probing interrogation
episode 5 that helped kate realize why
exactly she wanted to be an avenger and
in another christmas movie homage kate
pulls a buddy of the elf on the elevator
buttons no no
come on that is so annoying
suka is russian for [ __ ] kate chases
elena in a cool lateral tracking shot
through the office space reminding us of
the awesome camera work in the movie old
boy and this means that on the hawkeye
set they likely had to build a whole set
with a dollhouse opening to roll in
front of but they do conceal a cut as
they move from the kitchen into the
lobby and here this firm is called
tanner d's and associates olivia tanner
was the set decoration coordinator for
the show courtney deez was a set
integration pa it's really cool how the
marvel shows will work in the names of
the cast and crew into the visual
details kate slings her bulla at elena's
widow staff to knock it out the window
and then they end up complimenting each
other as creepy baby santa in the corner
watches yelena anchors herself with that
repelling line and the camera reorients
with her as she scales down the building
i love how that christmasy empire state
building is framed perfectly behind her
and then kate has to jump out a window
the same way she saw hawkeye do when she
was a kid but miraculously lands
unharmed jack saves her proving he
really is just a naive dummy who loves
swords cool as the tracksuits creep up
on clint he lays these blinking red
grenades to cover the area which was the
same device that clint used on the
outriders who chased him in end game and
then clint tries to pull a john mcclane
out the window but he ends up more like
the wet bandits home alone whose zipline
also breaks and then he ends up stuck in
the tree where he meets the cutest owl
cute for now this owl is a reference to
an owl that was found in the 30 rock
christmas tree last christmas a cute owl
named rocky kate throws a tricycle
through the window of toy store fao
shores just like kevin mcallister does
to break the window and trip the alarms
to the toy store in home alone too and
she also stands on that big keyboard
just like tom hanks does at ivo shorts
and big kate timbers the tree by
breaking the wires and shooting an acid
arrow at the trunk calling back her
unintentional demolition of staintower
back in episode one and as the tree
falls you can actually see that owl
flying out of it i gotta say i'm getting
a little sentimental here at the end of
the year 2021 it's been a big year for
us covering every episode of all these
marvel disney plus shows and it's been a
delight sharing it with you but as big
as 2021 has been we've got even bigger
plans here in new rockstars for 2022 we
are gonna be expanding our output we're
gonna launch a new channel we're gonna
try to be even bigger and better next
year than we were this year and to help
us accomplish those goals we're gonna
need some serious computing power well
thanks to our friends at gigabyte we
have it we've been using the aorus 15pyd
model from gigabyte it has an 11th gen
intel cpu and an nvidia genforce rtx
3080 graphics processing unit that's
great for streaming content and for
gaming look at that rainbow glow on the
keyboard and look at that display it was
designed in partnership with the
professional g2 esports team and its
strong processing power and fast refresh
rates makes for smooth gameplay on the
latest games with its eight hour battery
life and ridiculous cooling this is a
great laptop for travel or coffee shops
or staring at it for hours trying to
read the fine print on tv show newspaper
we've used this around the office a
bunch for editing videos streaming and
of course watching a bunch of content
our editors have been blown away by its
speed if you're looking to upgrade your
laptop check out the aorus 15p and other
great options at gigabyte.com and you
can get this featured laptop in the link
below on the ice clint uses the magnetic
arrow to snatch all of their guns and
clint reveals he wore his new suit
underneath his torn shirt a classic
superhero shortcut proving he has come
full circle on that branding issue then
they just unleash all the trick arrows
in the tracksuits it is awesome kate
once again uses her bow as a springboard
uses her legs to tackle a guy the way
black widow would do but the most
unsettling arrow of course is that red
glowing pim arrow that shrinks the
tresta bro truck what happens to them
now i don't know
i'll tell scott about that yes telling
us that clint might have gotten this
tech from scott directly not hank pym
and that clint in scott's partnership
after civil war continued but then the
owl snatches him away in no joke the
captions of this episode label their
squeaky screams as children shouting
this is the most horrific mcu death
since darren cross shrunk hank into a
plop of twitching goo so that owl either
fed these tiny humans to its children or
used its talons to crush them and then
pull them apart limb by limb with its
beak marvel please pymtech deaths are
terrifying and we kind of love them
clint does that same trick of splitting
a wooden arrow in midair by firing a
second arrow which he argued to kate
back in episode 4 was possible no it's
not impossible the first arrow you
release just has to be wood so when you
release the second one splits it right
up the middle i call [ __ ]
i've tried it well i've done it a few
times but cassie catches the middle
arrow the way loki does in avengers
which just makes me think that this guy
has got to be juiced on something a lot
of the tracksuits are or it could just
be the show suddenly remembered that
this character existed and decided to
give him something to do i mean in this
episode a lot of cassie's dialogue is
awkwardly adr in you know what i have to
do don't make me do this maya i don't
know it just looks like they had to
reconfigure a lot of this in
post-production to bring many of these
subplots to a close in a sixth episode
cassie tells maya
i guess callie back to william's advice
to maya in episode three but other than
that photo of the three of them together
and then the references to kazi being
his number two we never really feel any
context to william and kazzy's
relationship for this callback to make
sense to come from kazi clearly for
rafi's role in this series was super
trimmed down it's a bummer elena asks
clint what happened to natasha your
sister sacrificed herself she saved the
world i'm sorry
you're lying i love the shock
composition with elena because behind
her that fallen christmas tree with all
of its lights looks like infinite
infinity stones that are all out of
focus because she doesn't care about the
dumb rainbow rock stakes that natasha
gave her life over in truth neither does
clint anymore kingpin rips off eleanor's
door literally opening the door to
possibility this time after the netflix
show made him famous for slamming
kartour's clothes kate plunges an arrow
into his chest but it has no effect
kingpin in the comics is bulky because
of layers of muscle in a daredevil he
wore body armor but the kingpin of this
show is also super strong he's getting
plowed through windows of buildings he's
ripping off car doors he's punching
people across rooms i'm wondering if
this kingpin strength may also be a
factor of a dosage of some kind of super
soldier serum kate notices him adjusting
his cuff links and then yeah he gets
rammed into the toy store and kate
bravely engages this huge man despite
his insane strength he snaps her trick
arrows but then she uses this because
she leaps on his arm where she saw him
adjusting the cuff link and you can see
the moment she snatches that cufflink
from his sleeve that was her objective
so then she uses clint's coin flicking
trick to activate that one magnetic
arrow which starts a chain reaction to
the too dangerous one but also triggers
that sonic blast and that cluster bomb
arrow all at once these all cook fisk
and then he lies motionless and in that
shot you can see the cuff link missing
kate has her mom arrested mrs bishop
you're under arrest for the murder of
armand de kane iii turn around please
yeah i'm pretty sure this scene was
re-shot as well because the background
looks like a plate the detective's lines
are off-screen and the detective we do
see has just a really weird eye line hey
who are you looking at i think eleanor
might also have been reworked in
post-production because we never really
see her kill armond see her kill anyone
i'm betting that there was an alternate
ending with her character maybe her
dying instead of just getting arrested
like this clint is able to turn elena by
repeating that whistle that she shared
with her sister
[Music]
[Applause]
and clint reveals how natasha told him
about the events in the black widow
prologue escaping ohio on a plane being
separated from elena and doing so he
reverts elena to her american pie
singing innocence before she became a
killer clint apologizes to her and elena
decides to leave probably to pave a
future on some dark avengers or
thunderbolts line up with val and john
walker and notice how only now it begins
to snow this tells us that the final
scene of spider-man no way home in which
peter parker swings through 30 rock
plaza past the tree while around the
same time might have been a different
night because that tree was still
upright and it was fully snowing in that
scene so don't worry we don't have to
look in the background for peter
swinging around here and in the spot in
the toy store where kingpin was once
lying down in the background nutcrackers
flank an empty throne considering how
much the tracksuits self-identified with
nutcracker music you could interpret
these as the tracksuits who now protect
an empty throne at least temporarily
empty with kingpin's latest setback
which we see in the next scene as maya
finds him and points a gun at him
sometimes family doesn't see
eye to eye
yes the camera pulled up before we saw a
body so no corpse no death what happened
snowman in the window what did you see
well yes we do hear both a gunshot and a
thud to the ground but notice how
kingpin said i to i that has got to be a
nod to the similar moment in the
daredevil comics when daredevil tells
echo about kingpin's lies and echo
shoots kingpin in the face but we later
find out that he's just blinded by this
and he actually later on after that gets
some reconstructive surgery so i'm
betting we will see kingpin in the mcu
again but the next time he will be
temporarily blind or maybe with an eye
patch but fully blind would make him a
more interesting foe to maya lopez in
the echo series and of course the
perfect foe to daredevil who also now
joins the mcu clint lets kate join him
on christmas day to the barton farm
notice how clint smiles at the front
porch that might be because sitting in
that bucket is the baseball glove that
he recovered from his son during the
time heist trial and end game to prove
that things could be removed from the
past and prove that he could reunite
with his family kate brings the dog
along
that's lucky as expected they settled on
the name lucky as the dog is named in
the fraction comics and clint returns
that rolex to laura and on the back is a
shield logo laura's face reflecting in
that shield and the number 19 which is a
reference to shield agent 19 the
designation for mockingbird bobby morse
in the comics but in this case the
number for laura barton at least before
she retired this explains laura's
espionage professionalism throughout the
series and makes tony stark's first
words upon meeting laura and age of
ultron super ironic this is an agent of
some kind outside clint and kate
barbecue the ronin suit and as they
return to the house brainstorming names
for her settling on the title of hawkeye
in the foreground the archery target
comes in a frame the same target from
clint's opening scene in avengers in
game that was the moment that truly
began this final chapter of clint's
journey final we think and now kate
bishop helped bring him home and then we
get a post credit scene showing the full
save the city song from roger's musical
the conductor is actually a cameo by the
composer of that song mark shaman who
wrote the music and the lyrics alongside
scott whitman both of them longtime
broadway greats behind hairspray and a
number of other titles little new
details i got here when the cat
performer hits his big note his shield
mike wazowski's the hawkeye performer
who awkwardly has to move out from
behind it but there's also a crazy cut
in this moment where hawkeye goes from
being on cap's left to being right
beside hulk and then in the final part
of the song thor and loki hold hands all
another reminder to check out our
strange entitlement shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com and thank you so
much for joining me in these breakdowns
of hawkeye and of all the marvel
breakdowns we have done in 2021 we're
gonna take a little break from marvel
content next week but we got some great
boba fett content headed your way and
then we will back in full force covering
everything we normally cover in the
first week of january in the meantime
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything marvel thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]